public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
président du modem conseiller politique
d' emmanuel macron françois bayrou est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité - yahoo
et maire de pau bien sûr je n'oublie pas
votre mandat électoral françois bayrou
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
alors que la campagne du second tour est
désormais évidemment bien engagé vous
répondrai au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions que viendront
vous posez jean-francis pécresse de
radio classique et des échos jérémy
marot de la fp et mickaël szames s de
public sénat première question comment
mobiliser face au front national
deuxième question quelle majorité demain
pour gouverner alors qu'au ps et chez
les républicains
certains sont prêts à vous rejoindre
enfin troisième question à quoi
ressembleront les premiers mois de la
présidence et pentue elle d' emmanuel
macron mais tout de suite une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
est-ce que emmanuel macron a commis une
erreur de jeunesse j'ai envie de dire de
novices en donnant l'impression dimanche
soir de fêter déjà sa victoire dans ce
contexte où l'on voit le front national
très puissant et un pays fracturée alors
j'entends cette polémique ou ce semblant
de polémique
il est allé boire un pot avec son équipe
et mangé un morceau dans une brasserie
absolument classique parisienne et donc
il n'y a pas la moindre ombre de de
fêter quoi quelques victoires que ce
soit ils ont fait ensemble pris un pot à
la fin du premier tour et deux mois et
de mois de un combat difficile donc je
saigne animal il était envoyé ce qu'ils
étaient influencés par les commentaires
que celui de fleury sur il a réalisé le
hold up du siècle large le jeu ne pleut
pas la moelle a publié mois qui lui
parle assez souvent je pense qu'il a
tout à fait
la sensation de la gravité de la
situation et du poids de la tâche qui va
être la sienne
et c'est cela qui est pour moi
l'essentiel après quand on quand on
arrive en tête d'une élection alors que
présidentielle alors que c'est la
première fois qu'on se présente aux
suffrages
bien entendu il ya le sentiment qu'on a
réalisé quelque chose qui était pour le
moins inattendu c'est incontestable et
donc à la fin on a l'habitude de dire
qu'il faut trente ans pour être devenir
président de la république lui en moins
de 12 mois il n'a plus qu'une marche à
gravir pour rentrer à l'elysée
et puis il a fait alors exploser le
système c'est à dire ce que vous vous
attendez depuis quinze ans avant l'arrêt
ou bien j'ai j'ai aidé et je l'aide dans
cette tâche quitté de salubrité
nationale et donc cette question est
importante elle est posée comme ça de
manière anecdotique comme si c'était un
contour une histoire qu'on raconte mais
c'est pas ça du tout la question la
question ce qui a des moments où les
pays ont besoin d'un bol d'air frais un
moment où on est tellement au bout de
deux de la lassitude de de l'
exaspération à l'égard de blocage de
système qui marche plus qu' il ya des
moments où les pays se tournant vers une
vision nouvelle vers un regard nouveau
une recomposition et pas seulement vers
est un homme nouveau une personnalité un
homme nouvel e jeune et qui en effet à
est sortie du cadre qu'on voulait lui
tracé est en tout cas pour moi qui
attend ce moment depuis tellement
longtemps
je considère que c'est un moment clé de
l'histoire quand elle que vraiment vous
avez fait la fête dimanche soir même si
vous n'étiez pas à la rotonde je n'étais
pas là haut tombe jeudi soir y aller
j'étais invité mais je moi je pense que
les moments de joie les plus importants
sont les plus retenus tout de suite la
première question posée désormais par
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
bonsoir ça c'est voir michel bonsoir
françois bayrou elle reçoit visière on
voit marine le pen qui tente de
mobiliser contre emmanuel macron comment
comptez vous vous y prendre pour
mobilisez-vous contre marine le pen
il n'y a rien de plus simple il suffit
de dire la vérité
si on suivait les directions que madame
le pen propose on aurait le malheur pour
la france est en france pour les plus
faibles de la france
on aurait le malheur parce que si on
sortait de l'euro pour revenir au franc
la monnaie se casserait la figure et que
donc les retraites par exemple ne
vaudrait plus le montant du chèque que
le pouvoir d'achat s'effondrerait on
aurait d'incroyables difficultés
budgétaires par exemple tous ceux qui
veulent emprunter pour construire une
maison pour acheter une voiture pour de
l'électroménager y verrez les taux
d'intérêts explosé et ceci est si
vérifier au travers du monde chaque fois
qu'on a essayé ça que d'une certaine
manière il nous revient à tous comme
citoyen comme spécialiste pour vous
comme citoyen pour moi de dire la vérité
au pays et cette vérité sera
mobilisatrice vous voyez que je jeu par
des propositions sans même évoquer les
arrière pensées qui sont des
arrière-pensées extrêmement dangereuse
de division des français sur les sujets
les plus explosifs qu'on peut trouver
qui touche à l'origine de
d'où viens tu quelle est ta religion que
qui est ennemie avec qui tout cela comme
vous savez j'ai toute ma vie voulu
réconcilier les français dépassé les
frontières et les antagonismes le
persuader ce peuple qui l'a beaucoup
plus en commun pour se rassembler qu'il
n'a pour se diviser et pour moi en tout
cas c'est un combat de deux de chaque
seconde combat intérieur et combat dans
le débat public question mais marine le
pen elle est laissée depuis hier de
convaincre les français que celui qui va
les appauvrir sait pas elle mais c'est
emmanuel macron les deux au fond montrer
aux atouts l'électorat que le projet
dangereux économiquement c'est pas son
projet c'est le projet des manuels mâcon
messas comme vous savez c c'est de
l'argumentaire politiciens la question
est que mais est ce que vous avez
apporté quand même auprès de ces
français qui sont réfractaires qu'elle a
ses arguments économiques que vous
développez que développe 25 prix nobel
de l'économie que développe ceux qui
font marcher l'économie c'est à dire
tous les patrons mais qui se heurte
quand même à une sorte de mur de
l'incompréhension et j'admire 30% des
français accusés mois s'il y a annulé
les votes de marine le pen
je ne crois pas que ce soit les mains je
pense que jean luc mélenchon à dimanche
soir arte en profondeur le nombre de
ceux qui lui avaient fait confiance où
un grand nombre de ceux qui essaient
confiance parce que le
au fond dans ceux qui ont apporté leur
soutien émaneront il y avait l'idée que
vraiment c'était le contraire de
l'extrême droite et donc il ya eu là
quelque chose qui a été très je suis sûr
très blessants pour un grand nombre de
gens payent donc est-ce que vous je suis
sûr qu'il ya des millions de gens et
comprennent et pas choqué très
simplement que jean luc mélenchon n'est
pas appelé à voter contre marine le pen
moi je suis et a voté la paix fait j'ai
été stupéfait qu'il ne se prononcent pas
dimanche soir j'aurais parié à peu près
de tout ce que j'avais que ça ne serait
pas le cas sont blessés tous ceux qui
avaient mis leur confiance ou en tout
cas l'immense majorité
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez dire d'ici
dimanche 7 mai aux électeurs de droite
hormis le simple fait de leur dire fait
barrage à l'extrême droite qu'est ce que
le voulait qu'est-ce qu'il faut lors je
pense que la question de la france est
en jeu dans cette élection et je pense
que la grandeur de la france la dignité
de la france et l'honneur de la france
et le le lien entre français tout cela
est en jeu dans cette élection
et contrairement à ce que vous croyez
j'espère vous faire partager ce
sentiment
je ne fais pas de différence dans le
discours entre s'adresser à une partie
de l'électorat qu'on appelle de droite
s'adressait à une partie de l'électorat
qu'on appelle de gauche
je pense que tout cela sont des citoyens
français et que tout cela on dans les
douze jours qui viennent maintenant à
mesurer l'importance de leur choix c'est
cette importance là qui moi me mobilise
et qui me et qui me pousse en arriver à
la passion de sept engagés emmanuel
macron s'il est élu contrairement à
jacques chirac en 2002 il aura entendu
l'appel le soutien
des électeurs venus de tout l'échiquier
je suis persuadé je suis persuadé que
oui et d'ailleurs la démarche politique
qu'il a choisie qui ressemble en effet
la démarche politique que j'ai toujours
essayé de défendre c'est précisément de
ne pas faire de séparation dans ceux qui
ont envie de le suivre ou de lait d
entre eux les camps l'effraction et les
parties merci jean français donc c'est
jérémy marc os de l'iphone qui nous
rejoint maintenant l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir amis sur michel bonsoir monsieur
bayrou alors vous refusé d'imaginer
l'hypothèse d'une marine le pen qui
accède au pouvoir le 7 mai on se rejette
le 7 mai au soir emmanuel macron est élu
avec qui il gouverne avec quelle
majorité gouverne avec la majorité que
lui donneront les français que lui ont
donné les lui auront donné les français
s'il est élu parce que s'il est élu
c'est que précisément la majorité des
français aura choisi de lui apporté son
suffrage et son soutien ça constitue une
majorité à partir de cette majorité
présidentielle
il va former une majorité législative et
je n'ai pour ma part aucun doute que
comme ils l'ont fait à chaque élection
sans exception les français l'ayant élu
président de la république lui donnerons
les moyens de gouverner et les parties
comment dirais-je qui ne sont pas au
deuxième tour qui ont été écartés par
les citoyens c'est parti là qui essaye
d'expliquer que var l'élection
législative on pourra empêcher le
président de la république de gouverner
se trompent
pour vous les avancées ne lui a de
risques de l'évidence et ne le suivront
pas la cohabitation je conseille enfin
moi je suis je crois de toutes mes
fibres que les français seront cohérent
seront simplement tireront les
conséquences des choix qu'ils ont fait
en donnant au président de la république
élu la majorité qui lui permettra de
gouverner et ça aura un autre avantage
c'est que cette majorité permettra de
renouveler profondément les visages de
la vie politique française alors d'ores
et déjà il faut préparer aussi les
élections législatives en attendent
toujours d investiture pour l'instant
seulement 14
mieux tant mieux mais je veux dire le
l'idée qu'on peut lui ré ou qu'on
troublerait ou qu'on ne pèserait sur
l'élection présidentielle par la
distribution d'investiture pour des
élections législatives qui vont venir
plusieurs semaines après est une idée
baroque
en tout cas moi je considère que c'est
une idée qui qui n'est pas cohérente
tout le monde sait que quand il ya des
investitures ça provoque des sentiments
mitigés chez les uns et chez les autres
chez tous ceux qui pensent ou
souhaiteraient avoir ces investitures
c'est donc pas le moment
en plaine entre les deux tours d'une
élection présidentielle d'annoncer des
investitures aux législatives
en tout cas telle est mon sentiment
pourtant emmanuel macron l'a annoncé l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises il y aura une
vague d'investiture entre les deux tours
s'était dit encore la dernière maj ou en
attendent beaucoup peut-être l'at-il dit
mais si j'ai un conseil
elle rappelle pas si j'ai un conseil à
exprimer c'est que il faut se concentrer
sur l'élection présidentielle faut se
concentrer sur la question qui est posée
aux français pour une fois dans une
absolue transparence que que voulez-vous
que soit l'avenir de notre pays vous
avez deux propositions politiques qui
sont en effet deux propositions
politiques qui ne qui ne disent pas la
même chose de la france et de l'avenir
de la france et je n'ai pas de doute que
les français vont se prononcer de
manière absolument clair qu'ils vont
répondre à cette question et tous les
tous les moments de d'authenticité pour
le pays permettent de répondre à cette
question qui est une question de devis
des citoyens nous avons envie de former
un pays rassembler et pas un pays divisé
nous avons envie de nous respecter et
pas de nous mépriser
nous avons envie tiens j'étais ce matin
peut-être vous aussi l'avez-vous suivi
aux obsèques du policier du jeune
policier qui a et nous l'avons fait
vivre ont tous été bouleversés par
history entendu j'ai été moi bouleversé
par le discours du compagnon de du jeune
policier tué c'était un discours
magnifique de di tu es magnifique de
justesse magnifique de générosité et ce
discours était du côté d'un pays qui se
rassemblent et pas d'un pays qui qui qui
fait prospérer des divisions et des
ressentiments et pourtant dieu sait que
quand on perd un être cher dans des
circonstances comme celles là il ya
toutes les raisons d'être habité par
cette et bien non c'est le il a donné ce
ce jeune homme un superbe exemple
en tout cas je les ai entendus comme tel
et tout le monde était bouleversé
quelles que soient les opinions
vous avez vous gardé des larmes dans les
yeux de tous ceux qui étaient là et je
vous jure qu'à cet instant il n'y avait
aucune aucune idée de aucune volonté
d'aller vers ce pays en affrontement où
on voudrait nous entraîner parlant de la
droite justement pour l'instant un seul
parlementaire a rejoint en marche c'est
le sénateur jean baptiste lemoyne la
droite reste pour l'instant groupe et
comment ne pas rater l'ouverture vers la
droite et convaincre ces parlementaires
de vous rejoindre et de gouverner alors
quand vous dites que ce ce parti reste
groupé c'est que vous ne lisez pas les
articles que vous écrivez officiellement
il ya une position commune maintenant il
ya des individualités qui s'exprime par
exemple alain juppé alain juppé dit
qu'il faut or et réorienter la politique
de son parti donc dans une politique
humaniste européenne et là vous vous
seriez peut-être que parfait trait
d'union ont vu votre proximité avec
nuages épais en traversant les couloirs
du sénat pour venir à votre émission
j'ai rencontré plusieurs parlementaires
2 de l air de l'ump devenu l air et tous
disent aimer c'est pas possible qu'on
ait une position comme ça faut qu'on
dise des choses claires alors je ne dis
pas que c'est l'unanimité puisqu'il
paraît qu'ils se sont divisés je dis que
c'est le sentiment de responsabilité
quiconque éprouve un grand nombre de
ceux qui sont les cadres et les
animateurs de ce mouvement et il me
semble que dans les heures qui viennent
ou dans les jours qui viennent a
beaucoup de ceux là vont s'exprimer avec
un appel beaucoup de ceux là vont
s'exprimer pour dire clairement vers qui
va leur choix et que nul ne puisse
mettre en cause les orientations qu'ils
vont exprimer ce bayrou veut s'attacher
à la transparence d'un anneau d et vous
donne
je veux je ne suis par les assauts sur
l'estran si je ne sois pas vous voyez
vous connaissez beaucoup donné à
l'egypte les négations vos contacts avec
lui en jeu le mans je le dis en quoi ça
va des bras et je ne me sens pas
autorisés à faire des déclarations à la
place de ceux qui en sont les
responsables sauf que vous vous avez des
contacts directs avec alain juppé je
reviens sur ce sujet et donc chacun
s'exprimera et je ne doute pas de la
force de leur expression non seulement
considèrent qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
pris en compte la présence du front
national au second tour il a déclaré
aujourd'hui 20 1 françois hollande bon
on est dans une situation de transition
et mais il s'est exprimé clairement le
problème c'est que il n'aurait pas fallu
laisser grandir les raisons qui ont fait
le succès du front national et ceci je
n'impute pas françois hollande eux
uniquement jeunes impute à une longue
période dans laquelle le la la pratique
politique n'a pas donné les résultats
que les citoyens étaient en droit
d'attendre en remercie jeremy 15 ms tout
de suite nous rejoint pour la dernière
partie de l'épreuve de vérité
[Musique]
bonsoir michael st michel ou son
monsieur bayrou bonsoir emmanuel macron
ne crois pas aux 100 premiers jours d'un
président at il tort je comprends très
bien ce qu'il dit quand il dit que ce
n'est pas son son approche des choses
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qu'il faut
faire dans les 100 premiers jours et des
engagements qu'il a pris
il y en a par exemple c'est que avant
l'élection les élections législatives
il nous poserons il posera sur la table
du conseil des ministres
une loi de moralisation de la vie
publique seniora ce que je dis pas que
ce soit l'urgence je dis que ça on peut
le faire en quelques jours
on peut écrire cette loi avec les
différents aspects qui doivent être les
siens par exemple une guerre sans pitié
contre les conflits d'intérêts où les
soupçons de conflit d'intérêts est ce
qu'on appelle conflit d'intérêts c'est
très simple c'est quand l'intérêt privé
l'emportent sur l'intérêt général que
l'on fait en sorte que la décision
publique
elles soient prises pour au bénéfice
d'intérêts privés 14h06 1 à un homme
politique d'avoir un autre métier comme
avocat interdire à un homme politique
d'être le conseil comme on dit entre
guillemets de deux des sociétés qui
pourraient avoir intérêt à ses choix et
donc ceci se fait dans tous les autres
pays démocratiques d'europe en tout cas
deuxièmement il faut avoir une certitude
que le financement de la politique
devient clair au début il y aura les
dossiers économiques et sociaux emmanuel
macron annoncé au doute
une nouvelle loi travail il l'a exprimé
d'ailleurs sur public sénat en
l'écoutant une réforme par ordonnance je
propose qu'une concertation accéléré en
début de quinquennat et sur ce sujet là
qu'on fonctionne par ordonnance pour le
faire durant l'été pourquoi parce qu'il
ya besoin d'un choc de confiance d'une
vraie accélération d'une détermination à
l'épreuve et parce que nous avons besoin
de faire passer cette réforme pour que
les premiers effets se fassent sentir
assez rapidement vous confirmez
les concertations quand ça passe et
chaque de france et chef de confiance et
ces deux mots sont deux mots clés avec
le risque de on a vu ce que ça a donné
avec la loi elle conneries non mais
comment faire l'élection présidentielle
va intervenir l'élection présidentielle
donne au président un mandat l'élection
législative les élections législatives
vont suivre elle donne à la majorité et
au gouvernement un mandat est de ce
point de vue là oui la légitimité est
plus forte que celle des gouvernements
précédents qui avaient qui d'une
certaine manière faisait un peu le
contraire de ce qu'ils avaient dit qu'il
ferait comprenez c'est pas la même chose
d'agir lorsque vous avez un mandat
d'agir en dehors de tout mandat et le et
le travail qui lie à faire je vous
rappelle que les ordonnances
elles sont votées à l'assemblée vous
êtes habile y penser maintenant c'est
quelque chose qui vient d'infliger il ya
des sujets sur lesquels on peut ou on
doit avancer par ordonnance pour éviter
l'enlisement dans lequel on vit depuis
trop longtemps
l'enlisement ça ressemble aussi à ce
qu'on avait entendu par le 49-3 ça se
ressemble un petit peu ou pas c'est pas
exactement mon sentiment
moi je pense que le 49-3 a été choquant
parce que le débat n'a pas eu lieu avec
des ordonnances le débat aura lieu donc
il ya un débat sur la loi d'habilitation
par ordonnance le gouvernement vient
devant le parlement
et il dit au parlement qu elles vont
être ses orientations et ses choix et le
parlement lui donne cette cette
habilitation
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre dans
l'entre-deux tours vous avez
certainement dû en parler avec emmanuel
macron a peut-être une mesure sorti du
chapeau
concernant les syndicats je déteste le
mot sorti du chapeau n'est pas c'est pas
de la prestidigitation
le train qui n'a pas encore été annoncée
à grands va préférer va avoir à en effet
expliciter les choix qui sont les siens
certains qu'il a déjà annoncé qu'ils
n'ont pas été entendus
parce que le brouhaha de la campagne
électorale empêcher qu'ils fussent
tentant but et peut-être d'autres qui
l'expriment ça pourrait ressembler à
quoi notamment une plus forte présence
dans les conseils d'administration je ne
je ne sais pas si vous avez compris mais
je ne suis pas le candidat à la
présidence la république peut-être il
cela commence voulait pas nous dire que
vous savez ce qu'on pourrait enseigner
donc oui en tout cas je parle avec lui
je ne suis pas je suis pas dans une
fonction de conseiller
il vient de nouvelle loi sur le sur les
marchés du travail notamment raids
notamment de renforcement des relations
et kristen cas vous ne risquez pas n'est
pas crainte d'avoir une rentrée sociale
importante avec des gens dans la rue et
notamment ceux qui ont voté pour une
personne jean luc mélenchon qui était
plutôt dans la contestation et bien je
ne le crois pas pour parler de la
légitimité mais pour cela il faudrait qu
emmanuel macron obtiennent quel
pourcentage le devoir se sera pas les 80
% de chirac n'attendez pas de rouiba les
80% de jacques chirac n'ont pas donné la
légitimité qu'il aurait fallu
précisément parce que jacques chirac a
choisi à l'époque il a écrit depuis
qu'il le regrettait a choisi à l'époque
de au fond de ne pas tenir compte de de
l'importance de la base de ce qu'ils
avaient apporté leur confiance
mais manuel mac on ne veut pas d'un
nouveau projet de loi de finances
rectificatif
et c'est à dire que le dernier budget du
quinquennat de françois hollande est le
grand lit dès que emmanuel macron
développe c'est que en matière de
finances publiques il faut respecter ses
engagements
il ya beaucoup de gens qui rêvait ou
proposés dans cette élection de ne plus
respecter les engagements - j'apprécie
que emmanuel à qu'on dise nous allons
respecter les engagements de la france
j'ai une petite dernière question plus
personnelle si vous le permettez merde
peau vous êtes vous resterez après le 7
mai eh bien nous verrons ensemble
comment je peux répondre à deux
impératifs que je vais rappeler devant
vous le premier c'est que je suis
attachée à ma ville et que je resterai
dans cet attachement et que je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour qu'elle se
développe dans du mayet maire et le
deuxième je ferai tout ce que je peux
pour que mon pays ce tir se sortent de
la crise dans laquelle il est vous voyez
que ce sont deux engagements qui sont
condamnant chrtr complémentaire je vais
vous dire pourquoi que par salia le
cumul des fonctions
un citoyen de pau il a deux
appartenances y les citoyens de cette
ville formidable et en même temps il est
citoyen français et sa vie elle dépend
du développement de la ville et du
redressement du pays
donc non dans deux ans pendant que
j'avais tout ce que je pourrai pour
remplir ces deux engagements avec le
même temps que mme en même temps à oman
et en même temps de responsabilité une
d'élus et une au service de l'exécutif
eh bien nous verrons nous verrons
verront ces c'est uniquement le
président de la république et lui qui
peut décider de ce genre de jouer en
toute confidence vous allez nous dire
qu'on n'en avait pas parlé encore avec
lui je n'ai jamais voulu te dernière
question vous avez eu un éclat de rire
marc est jeune on je voudrais vous dire
une chose et moi très simple je vous
crois il ya des gens qui racontent des
histoires à et moi je m'efforce de dire
la vérité
c'est surprenant sur ce plateau et
américains dans le tout les gens que
vous invitez vous raconte nicolas
sarkozy variant de 2 à nicolas en tout
cas quand je vous dis que je n'en ai pas
parlé avec lui c'est que je n'en ai pas
la sarkozy va annoncer qu'ils votent
macron sais ce que c'est ce qu'annonce
la fp vous saluer ou le salut et la peau
dure le le choix responsable c'est celui
qu'on annonce pourrir la sarkozie échos
et que vont prononcer un grand nombre
d'autres responsables du parti les
républicains je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils
vont tous s'extraire de le 2 de cette
ambiguïté pour prononcer le choix
civique que la france attend merci à
vous on va continuer à suivre cette
campagne sur public sénat et demain
d'ailleurs il y aura une nouvelle
épreuve de vérité avec ferran philippe
pour le numéro 2 du front national quand
soir à demain
[Musique]